welcome everybody to another episode of
the h3 podcast live every Friday at
twitch.tv for slash issue your options
except sometimes it's not on Friday
thank you to Omaha Steaks lift me on DS
and honey for sponsoring this episode
the H Street podcast if you guys have
any questions for us or a guest today
give us a ring at eight one eight two
one four eight five zero for next week
there's a lot there's some housekeeping
stuff to get you on that house you keep
showing sometimes it surprised me how
much housekeeping we have but anyway
Michaels here I'm gonna do like an
official intro I just want to say we
have some houses keep shelling you're
doing good don't agree next week I'm
very excited to say that we have Brendan
green coming on to the podcast
aka player unknown the creator of the
massive successful pub G is the director
designer producer aka the new knotch
right very excited that episode will be
at an irregular time Wednesday the 20th
at 3 p.m. leave your questions for him
on the subreddit I'll be throwing that
up here after this live broadcast I
forgot to put it up today's guest is a
saucy fellow AV saucy fellow if you will
we all know him and we all love him he's
Michael and he's you've recently
ascended from a science guy to a living
meme status I would say I think the
Vsauce memes are in high demand as far
as the meme economy is concerned he just
came out with in second season of
YouTube red series mindfield was just
released and I had a excellent time
watching it and he's got one of the best
channels on YouTube Vsauce
very honored and thrilled to introduce
once again to the show Michael thank you
great to be yeah yeah after being here
for the groundbreaking of this very
studio I'm back it's it's very cool you
are I think our first ever yes in this
studio it's a lot your friend first ever
was PewDiePie right yeah
and that was like in a some warehouse
right he had like a Airbnb in LA he
shooting scare PewDiePie right season 2
yeah I don't know if that yeah I think
that was season 2 Wow
we all know we all know how that one
ended a little season yeah one of my
favorites I was in it by the way did you
know that no kidding
music how you were in minefield where
like it disappear yeah and so it's kind
of like thanks for trying it was
actually much worse than that
I was a whole episode i hi i co-starred
mean HeLa both in an entire episode was
a kidding it was a whole [ __ ] thing I
got electrocuted bro for real yes
technically for those science fans out
there watching electrocuted means killed
if you didn't die you weren't
electrocuted so shocked
I'm sure there's some other word but
yeah electrocuted look at him you know I
believe you I believe you I'm just I've
said I'm not saying that I know shocks
me every word electrifying knowledge
electrocuted can I put my mouth right on
the mic it feels kind of good
yeah I prefer I basically I got more in
the better it sounds how did a lot of
famous mouths have been right up next to
these you get there's hep there's a
really passionate and tender kiss have
you ever seen me kid I'm all the sudden
jealous of your wife should be yeah
there's all kinds of hepatitis it's a
petri dish dish it's basically new with
new forms of STDs being transmitted to
your tongue right now glad to be part of
history cheers to that
mo Bradbury yeah that's once that
ellipse you may not this very Mike you
keep this Mike here and you guys use the
same mics every time yeah oh you do what
well I've been there before I don't this
is my mic I don't know what I don't I
don't let anyone use this mic where was
mo he was right there yeah we blue we
bleached it though when he was done
thank you I believed it like halfway
through the show protect me from myself
yeah like likes everybody how's the show
change I mean last time you were here we
had like
tape it was it was kind of a funky setup
right yeah I wasn't yeah which was very
comfortable now I'm I do feel kind of
tall with this chair being up high but
I'm afraid to move it cuz then the
Michael have to move it'll just the Mike
is very everyone yeah the micah yeah the
mike but what if I don't move it right
what if I get too low I just want to get
fishing you can really just manhandle
this thing okay well how are you how
have you been I mean how the hell is
life since we last spoke with you it's
great you know it's been it's been
fantastic I just got back from the brain
candy fall tour and that is you know
it's a it's a slog you know everyday you
got a show well six days a week and they
get one day off we perform in Kansas
City my hometown gave shout outs to some
teachers that made a difference in my
life when were there in the audience and
got to have my grandmother's come you
know couldn't really make it very far
away from Kansas City's having the show
there it was really cool that is very
cool you do it six out so how long do
these tours last because you says you do
it six times a week at once a day six
times a week so how long is that
duration it could be four weeks like
this fall one but in the spring we did
nine holy no break
I mean how level with me Michael how
awful is it yeah it's it's not because
here's the thing
Adam Savage has been traveling and
touring for years he knows how to make
it nice so we've got star coaches right
we've got rooms in the back of these
buses we drive overnight right you wake
up whenever you want to because you
don't have to worry about the show until
like 6:00 p.m. so you've got a day to
just lay in bed go to the dressing room
I could do a lot of work I can still
make my regular calls and I can visit
the cities I'm away from home I'm away
from my cats Millay from my wife I'm
away from the Vsauce office that's a
drag right but meeting people in person
is really important you know you can
watch a YouTube video and and engage
with me that way but when you meet in
person or when you turn it your whole
evening and it just coming to a live
show it's a bigger part of your life I
think you know you remember it longer
you've been to show yeah we really
we're in Costa Mesa right there's in
Santa Barbara Santa Barbara that's right
yeah so I remember it's a total blast
it's a total rock really the kids they
love the goddamn balls balls well
they're free yeah there's free balls I
mean guys free balls that you you really
you're selling tickets to bring candy
but we you should really be selling us
free balls free balls coming well
they're not free free it's lots of balls
and then underneath in parentheses brain
candy brain candy yeah paper balls balls
yeah stay for the candy yeah I found
that to be true as well I mean when you
meet a fan you writ that personal
connection or realizing that these like
real people watching your oh man and the
best thing is that especially because
I'm touring with Adam Savage a lot of
makers come to the shows people who have
a craft people who love to make things
and they make us stuff they make us wire
sculptures a guy made these muppet type
puppets of Adam and I that are just
phenomenal I mean it's not like I tried
it's like I'm a professional here
normally this would have probably been
thousands of dollars and I just made it
because I love making puppets and now I
have a puppet of myself which so you're
collecting treasures you collect
treasures that's that's powerful yeah
how I do get nervous before the shows I
mean this is a serious production and
there's a lot of people in the audience
create these you know it's it's a whole
or thing they come out tonight they come
out they watch you I mean you've done a
lot by now but walk me through the
process of of prepping yourself for that
and now after doing it for so long
dude does the nerve still affect you how
is it no the nerves don't affect me now
they did for that first show because I
had never done this I have no idea what
the show was gonna be like we'd run
through a few rehearsals with no one in
the audience but luckily you know Adam
and I are both pretty good at improving
something goes wrong if someone needs to
change we can just do that on the spot
and you start to get really familiar
with it and then I've got a background
of doing live performance ever since you
know high school giving informative
speeches and and that kind of stuff in
forensics and debate and so I got the
butterflies out like I feel comfortable
if something goes wrong I
can fix it yeah I feel like I would be
[ __ ] like my pants every [ __ ]
night we thought we've toyed with the
idea of doing a live tour and I just I
think I would I would I would have a
breakdown well it's too much stress you
might but not forever you know I'd get
over it forever not forever no you would
you would learn every night would be the
worst night of my life I feel it you
know I disagree okay I should do it I
like your encouragement yeah you'll be
super nervous the first the second the
third but then you'll start to be like
man I can't wait for this I can't wait
right so it's a fun thing for you now
you go onstage you do your thing you
look forward to it it's really fun I
mean it's the same show every night but
not really because there is no script
and so are always tweaking things before
the show will meet and I'll say you know
I think that joke would land better if
we did this or I think we should change
the order or I think we should explain
that part and then I'll explain this
part and then you can think you don't
understand and then I'll pretend
understand it's always really fun and
it's new to every audience right I've
seen the show or I'm in it but every
night it's a new city and it's new
people who were like hearing and seeing
these things for the first time you had
said that you guys are both really good
at improv and so when something goes
wrong you feel comfortable picking up
the pieces what's the most dramatic
thing that's gone wrong for you guys on
stage I fall a lot on stage
faceplant not a faceplant there was one
night it was in Canada I believe it was
in London Ontario where we didn't have
the right party fog juice normally we
use propylene glycol I believe and
instead we had this oil-based thing
which meant that a layer of oil formed
on everything on stage including before
me yeah so you know I danced in the show
as you've seen yeah but it wasn't even
during dancing it was just I was just
walking carrying this bottle of acetone
and boom slip hit the ground it was so
bad the like I needed to discuss it
during the QA and the middle of the show
because the audience was like okay and
also maybe that was the had to have been
scripted and planned because no way the
show would have gone on that's not even
the worst though the worst you ate [ __ ]
pretty hard
it sounds yeah yeah and I I'm a real
jumpy person so when I fall I don't just
like kind of you know fall I go because
I feel like me that'll be more
entertaining or everyone thinks I'm
really hurt another I fell and though
this this was the same the same show
with the oily floor I fall and I feel
while I'm falling I think you know what
I can save this if I start like
breakdancing maybe that's what I meant
to do right but there was a stagehand in
the way and I roll into him because of
course the floors covered in oil
I can't breakdance I can't breakdance
anyway but I also can't even like get
friction with the ground so I just slide
into him and killer show that sure we
couldn't get the oil out of it so was
that a good was that a favorite sure
yours it was a really good stage shirt
that's of London Ontario you guys were
the last ones I haven't seen any but I'm
sure the Michael or Mike Dan and hand
can you guys look up if there's Michael
eating [ __ ] on stage oh my god no
there's some just like dancing and not
falling Clips out there oh my god I hope
that's up there I mean that sounds like
a hell of a show if I'm being honest
yeah they were very lucky yeah they're
very fortunate people I again what my
next question for you is that I'm
fascinated by people who do a lot of
stuff thanks matey
thanks Dan I can't go I can't get a
break
people make fun of me because I say
fascinating a lot like I wonder how they
fascinating fascinating and every time I
say fascinating Dan hits the soundboard
to mock me fascinating fascinating I'm I
can't even say it
do I get to do I get passes should I get
some the F word the F word but the guest
won't know what I'm talking about
dance air Michael just confused right
now there's no idea what's going on
alright let's get I'm fascinated give me
a give me a breakdown give me a [ __ ]
pass on this one by showman or
productive professionals who manage so
many things in their lives because I
find myself always like overloaded and I
get flustered and lose focus when I have
too much [ __ ] do you
in minefield Vsauce brain candy of the
Curiosity box how do you manage all
these things at once and keep yourself
sane and focused I don't and I'm going
insane no I think what it is is it's um
it's about a great team to help you you
know I'm I'm involved with the Curiosity
box and help curate things but there's a
different team that packs them deals
with orders deals with getting samples
and I love what I'm doing that's kind of
a cliche answer but like when I wake up
in the morning I want to continue
reading about you know rigid rotational
dynamics you know because I just want to
and it happens to also be my job but if
I couldn't do that I'd be kind of like
annoyed mmm so it's I'm really fortunate
that my job happens to be what I do
anyway when I have free time but that
also means that I do I ever have free
time yeah I gotta take a break you say
okay I'm gonna stop what do you feel
like you have free time do you feel you
need free time does being so busy all
the time how does that affect your life
it doesn't affect my life because my
life was already even before YouTube the
same thing I just didn't have anyone to
listen to what I had discovered right I
would talk out loud to myself but then
with YouTube around I could just turn
who I was into a show a show right and
to get to get bigger than that to do a
live show to do the Curiosity Box to do
mine field you have to have other people
help and so wonder people work with you
and supporting you so gosh I mean there
were more than a dozen people on mind
field well and we had a number of actual
psychologists helping with
pre-production because the first season
was classic experiments it was stuff
that I knew because I had an
undergraduate degree in it and I was
like let's just replicate all of these
famous experiments we know the result to
expect and we kind of you know we know
we want to do but for season two I
wanted to go into what a psychologist
doing today and how are they doing it so
we had to bring in people who were
career psychologists who could then
reach out to different universities and
say what are you doing what can we help
you do we've got money we've got
resources we've got in some cases
cameras like an episode that isn't out
yet maybe it will be when you're
watching this was about the placebo
effect and how we're enchanted by
neuroscience that we believe it can do
more than maybe it really can and having
mine field there as a documentary crew
made people believe that the study was
more powerful than it was because of
course it was a placebo study but it
must be something if all these people
are here with cameras if this you know
if Michael Stevens is here it must work
and that was all part of of planting
that suggestion in their mind that
they're gonna get better mm-hmm that's
very cool I'm looking forward to uh
how there's another six episodes coming
on my field or what's the deal I think
were six already
I think there are three more there's
eight total and so far five have come
out so over the next year the next three
will come out so I wanted to talk about
the season to mine field actually
because you definitely it seems kicked
it up a notch from season one and I
appreciate you sacrificing your own body
of mine as guinea pig you dabbled in a
little bit season one with the
deprivation yeah but I loved the truth
serum and I loved the ayahuasca trip
tell me about how you guys came up with
that deer and I basically I just want to
hear like what was the experience like
let me start with the ayahuasca because
I feel like on the show I wanted to I
wanted to hear more about how was that
experience for you right because it was
[ __ ] it was a weird trippy thing like
it's one thing to take a psychedelic and
hang out with your friends as another
thing to hang out in like a jungle while
some robed man chants while you trip
balls and be recorded yes yeah yeah
there's like yeah that's a weird way to
do a psychedelic yes hey guys
rather than doing it in like my dorm
room I'm gonna do it in the middle of
nowhere where no one has cell connection
where the only way to get back to a city
is by taking a boat ride for hours lying
there was a measure of paranoia there
was a lot of fear and I don't think
you know we didn't record a lot of that
but I was really nervous as the date
approached because I couldn't say no I
could I made it very clear that like
look if we're gonna do this we all need
to agree that up until the moment I put
it to my lips I can say no and no one's
gonna be mad that we went all the way up
there because I didn't plan on not not
doing it but I wonder you want to
reserve the right I didn't want to feel
forced yeah
and so I said look when it comes to the
decision process and what we do and how
it works
that hierarchy goes me then the shaman
and then everyone else if the shaman
thinks that we need to have the lights
off if the shaman thinks I need to stop
recording and I can't respond you listen
to the shaman yeah I know he's not on
payroll I know you didn't approve him as
a director but did he get EP credit I
don't know what he got but he was a
great guy he was also our boat captain
oh he's uh he moonlights yeah yeah he
moonlights with the ayahuasca right yeah
but tell me about that experience
because I'm first of all was it your
first psychedelic experience as far as
my mother knows yes of course okay all
right yes not watching this isn't your
mother show and it was ah man I think
the the initial emotion I had before the
ceremony was aggravation really yeah
because I was nervous but I couldn't I
couldn't do it my way
what was your way my way would have been
to not have all the cameras there don't
have to make a show right and so this is
what's going through my mind I'm like
hanging out in the hut waiting for the
shaman and and his assistants to come
and get me but I can't just get picked
up and then taken to the the the
ceremony we have to like do multiple
angles and take the experience couldn't
be authentic it was it was totally
authentic but I had a job to do during
right yeah that was the hard part that I
couldn't just completely surrender
myself to the experience as me I had to
be Michael the host of mind field right
I had to listen to direction like ooh
you know what we have to do that again
because
this light was in the wrong place or oh
we need to get the coverage of the shot
of you entering and I'm fine doing that
but I had bigger things on my mind and
colors and shapes well I didn't even
know what kind of colors and shapes are
gonna be it was frightening
okay so then we've got a crew of people
right we've got something like eight
people there and they've got microphones
all around and usually you do this in
the complete darkness
that makes for a terrible show so we had
to have lights installed which made me
really self-conscious because not only
am I being watched and surrounded by
people you're expected to perform which
I can only imagine would be such an
awful feeling while you're tripping
right okay so expected to perform was
another concern I had so I also made it
clear that if if I do nothing but lay
there catatonic leave for eight hours
you're all gonna be happy a speed yeah
yeah because I don't want to have any
responsibility or obligation because
you're in a different state of mind yeah
and I can perform it's my career that's
my job I'm used to that in this state of
mind right
if I get hangry or grumpy or happy I can
still do those jobs but I wasn't
familiar with what it was like to be in
the state of mind that DMT creates so
luckily we had all that figured out and
it wasn't that big of an issue but I
felt really unhappy that I had to have
all these eyes on me and and then as the
drug started to take the effect I felt
feelings of guilt Here I am I was paid
to fly to Peru to take drugs and only I
got to take them no one else on the crew
had signed the right insurance paperwork
or would probably be able to do their
job properly if they had also taken it
so it'd been interesting though it could
have been interesting maybe for the
season three the boom yeah I mean the
shaman drank some okay well you would do
that but when you took a dose I was like
were you a little concerned when you saw
the shame and dip in yeah cuz I was
thinking wait I thought you were your my
god over me you're my guide bro yeah
but let me let me tell you this
in the the effects got stronger and
stronger my feelings of fear and guilt
and and cut the the self-awareness of
all the cameras on me that every motion
I did was gonna be caught and if i sat
up they'd have to reposition cameras and
I'd be aware of that and what if it
didn't work what if they needed to give
me some kind of direction and I wasn't
in the right state of mind
I've intial II realized hey as annoying
as it is to have all these cameras
around if we didn't have the cameras
here there wouldn't be a show and I'm
doing this for the audience I'm doing
this for Robin the researcher who was
there mm-hmm
it's not about me all of these concerns
about hey guys stop walking that noise
is frustrating or stop asking for the
coverage shots that's my job it's for
everyone else this is not for me and
starting to think about I need to just
give Robin I come come do the the the
EEG scan I'm ready for that I didn't
want to but then I realized by allowing
you to do it I'm giving it's not about
me and what I want it's about what
everyone's here for so that's a lesson I
took that from that afterwards citrus in
yeah how that's interesting that makes
you think about when when something is
your hobby and then becomes your job
it's kind of like it's not so much about
you anymore yeah that is kind of
profound yeah exactly
did you you've you felt that on a level
that you hadn't realized before yeah I
mean I literally envisioned myself as
this like waterfall that's just offering
its water to the world and I'm like I
remember sitting there going at some
point Robin has to come over and give me
a series of questions he's got to put
this thing on my head and measure the
electrolyte electrical activity there
and I could say no and I planned on
saying no until I realized the way to
get rid of all that anxiety was to just
say let's do this I am a vessel for your
research were you concerned from the
beginning that you weren't going to be
able to perform that hmm no I wasn't
really couldn't
because I figured even if it all
completely is messed up and we don't get
everything right that in and of itself
is whatever happens is good whatever
happens is well how did the experience
meet match up to your expectation let's
let's let's let's just assume that
you've taken other psychedelics let's
just imagine a world where you have how
would that hypothetically compare to
your experience well it's it's different
for every single person but anxiety was
my biggest fear because once you're
you're once you've drank the ayahuasca
it's you're you're on the ride like you
can't take the antidote right you know
and the first ceremony was really
Pleasant and and quite low in its dosage
the second one within 20 minutes I was
like oh no you took twice as much as I
recall you took like a third of a cup
the first time and then 3/4 of a cup
that's right yeah yeah and it happened
so fast
I had lost control I no longer was like
observing what was happening things were
just happening to me right and my heart
started racing right we had a medical
doctor there which normally you don't
because it's not dangerous basically but
YouTube requested that we have a yeah
yeah and so I was but here's the thing
my heart was going it was literally
beating very fast I actually there's a
moment where I touch my chest and I'm
like yep it's really happening but then
I thought how do I let the doctor know
because I can't think no this is not how
I normally feel is it weird if I just
say hey um help how are they going to
interpret that and so I just I thought
maybe I'll just ask for water you know
maybe that like will tether me back down
to reality because someone will have to
bring me water and that's a really
Mundus is so I've been that like I feel
like I've been in that headspace of
trying to like you're stuck between like
the ethereal world and the physical
world and trying to make sense of being
on another in another place and it's
frustrating I hate that it's frustrating
because I was probably most consumed not
by anxiety but by the feeling of
how do I relay and describe what's
happening to me later you know because
that's what always annoyed me about
discussions of psychedelic experiences
is that it all felt really vague and
hard to empathize with and now I I mean
I I know why it's it's like describing
colors to someone who's never seen it's
a completely different state of mind
right and so I I every a psychedelic
experience I've had I've hated it I
don't know why would you say it doesn't
sound like you quite hated it but it
seems like it was marked with some
negative feelings might yeah my
experience always have a lot of I think
my problem is like I'm too anchored I
never really let go and you're always
like resisting the urge to just kind of
float off and you're trying to hold on
to the earth as you're floating to the
sky
I think getting over that resistance is
there a part of what psychedelics teach
you right I didn't I didn't break from
that but I'm aware now of its existence
I know what it feels like Robyn Carhartt
Harris from Imperial College London who
came with me didn't say I had a bad trip
he describes it as a challenging trip
yeah you know I like that I'm still glad
that I did it but I'm not like I got to
do it again and I think that's fine you
know that's exactly it's fine yeah I
think I think if you're so that eager to
return to that state of mind you
probably having some trouble dealing
with the actual physical world if you're
so eager to its embarked out there and
and on a daily basis um I don't know but
I know that there's a bonus clip where
we spoke to a woman who took psilocybin
as part of this oh that's like mushrooms
yeah she took a pill through a study at
NYU and she worked with these
researchers for months and they crafted
a pill just for her based on her weight
based on her past they knew what dosage
to give her and they I think she felt
incredibly safe she wasn't in the middle
of this brand-new space therapies for
coping with death yeah she heard death
yeah because she had been diagnosed with
cancer and
confront your own mortality is obviously
frightening but they they were
experimenting with how psychedelics can
help you deal with those feelings mm-hmm
and she was it was a phenomenal
experience for her she she tells a story
of seeing a table with all of her family
and friends but also death is at the
table mm-hmm and she realized yeah
deaths invited of course hmm and and
ever since this happened years ago ever
since she's felt much better she's she's
you know felt healthier and she only
took that one pill it's not like just
it's one dose ah that's that that's
awesome I love that I think psychedelics
and and drugs like that really have a
lot of value to our society it's just
it's a shame that they get stigmatized
and I think that stigma itself is what
contributes to a lot of the negative
feelings you have when you take it I
think so too yeah
because you start to feel like oh my god
doing something wrong I'm doing
something wrong yeah in fact I had this
thought that cracked me up during that
second ceremony where I was like you
know what when the shaman lights the
candle and says that it's over first of
all it's very comforting because he
knows how long these experiences last
when he lights that candle it's proof to
me that the effects aren't only going to
wear down from now I mean it takes a
very long time but they when you're
going down you start to regain control
anyway I'm thinking you know once he
lights the candle and like the crews
done the first thing I'm going to say is
I can't believe I'm gonna have to tell
my mom I did this and such a funny thing
I didn't mind obscene it cuz it just
felt like a joke when the experience was
really traumatic and poignant but I
forgot what I was about to say you were
talking about the stigma how it makes
that oh yes I think that if if I was
part of the you know Shipibo indigenous
tribe where this is a medicine
prescribed all the time I would not have
felt the same kind of am i a bad ryerson
am I am i I mean this is illegal in the
country that I live
and I should feel bad that I'm doing
this this is a behavior that only bad
people do right and you have that social
baggage on you yeah it's interesting you
know I heard about a study that doctors
are starting to use MDMA to treat PTSD
so they give you a dose of MDMA which is
ecstasy in the pure form and they set
you down and I guess if it makes you
feel more comfortable talking up and you
feel more comfortable with the emotions
that you're dealing with and so all
these drugs that that I think it's a
shame I really think it's a shame this
war on drugs what is done
III genuinely believe that people yeah I
generally believe that people don't
abuse drugs unless there's something
else going on like people don't just all
the sudden become addicted at drugs I
think all drugs should be legal and
people should decide what they want to
do and if there's education and support
to help people navigate those waters
that we would be a healthier better
society in the word drugs what does it
mean because it sounds like so many
gangs everything from heroin to DMT
tylenol caffeine to tylenol right and so
we have done a disservice to both
ourselves and to innovation and
knowledge by saying ooh you're gonna
study psychedelics we really only want
to fund that if you're going to be
studying the bad side of them right and
only recently has that started to break
apart and we have this now renaissance
of investigation of psychedelics
Imperial College London has this whole
psychedelics research group and that's
who what Robin was from who came with us
and so we're starting to be able to
understand more about the mind because
you cannot have a complete theory of the
mind if you avoid or ignore something
that it's capable absolutely I mean it's
crazy I mean yeah we've tried some
obviously by now from the way we're
talking about it and it's it's weird to
see what your mind is capable of so I
was ashamed to do it on like a daily or
weekly or I don't I mean we don't do
anything now but we've tried it the
experience of trying something that is
really interesting just
to learn by your own body people are so
there's all these scares like you'd like
you take acid once and you lose your
mind I knew a guy who took acid and
[ __ ] jumped off a roof or he never
came back from the trip like these are
these are I swear to god these are all
just old wives tales that are just
designed to spook you I don't think that
really happens yeah when I was a kid
very very very rarely right well two
things one when I was a kid I read the
story about the guy who took LSD thought
he was an orange and locked himself in a
closet because he was afraid of being
juiced and there's no you think oh my
gosh how terrifying and and to be fair
this is a significant decision
this isn't like hey you know what I
should do is invest in gold right no you
really you should it's I don't think
anyone should I don't have any advice or
or I'm not gonna recommend to anyone
what they do it's their choice or maybe
the choice of medical professional
should make but the fact that you know
HeLa you're like well as you guys can
tell like maybe we have done something
that cajon is we have to have that yeah
I feel bad like even talking about it
because some people are gonna say oh you
guys are promoting oh yeah I don't
endorse it I don't recommend it I think
you like you shouldn't be able to talk
about it right and like I think like you
said it's a big decision to make for
yourself and I don't think that it needs
to be caged by law or stigma I think
that there should be open dialogue there
should be conversation and like go to a
place like places in Europe where drugs
are legal and they'll test it for purity
for you so that you don't take something
awful and die right yeah I can always
that you know where's it's some shady
stuff can hit me is that drug that shady
bad people are gonna own the market it's
not gonna be regulated and there's not
gonna be anything you're not gonna feel
like there's anyone there who can help
you or advise you through through the
experience something I found fascinating
was that when I spoke with Robin hit him
heaven with the den fascinating
fascinating
I asked Robin the head of the
psychedelics research group at Imperial
College London I'm like so what's your
experience with psychics assuming she's
done it he he sorry Robin Robin Robin
like Batman and Robin right he goes well
I don't talk about that
my grandmother might see they're such a
cop-out and I'm I'm saying that is that
is I was gonna say fascinating like that
is you see it's [ __ ] up yes that's
like drugs
it's the f-word I've got all the stigma
around they're a great example of the
stigma that's your job is to research
psychedelics and you can't say that
you've ever experienced them what other
scientists does that Oh mom I study
gorillas Oh have you ever seen any Oh No
yeah I would never look at a gorilla
right I talk to people who have looked
at them yeah or an imagined an
astronomer who's like yeah I've been
studying the Stars and the motions of
the planets I've never looked up yeah
don't judge me if I don't look up
I've talked to others who have and until
we break that barrier I think we're
really missing out on a big part of the
human mind it's a such a beautiful
paradox I think of this guy I love even
on a personal level he's like no no no I
don't talk about them yeah anyway listen
let's let's roll to a break quick thank
you to our sponsors and we will be right
back with your boy saucy saucy Vsauce
thank you to Omaha Steaks for sponsoring
this episode of the h3 podcasts listen
Omaha Steaks is a product that I am
fully behind you know that scene in Pulp
Fiction where they open this mystery
chestnuts like glowing orange well
that's basically what they send you
I received my package full of filets
sirloins pork chops in gabon size it
arrives in this chest with ice and you
open it's like glowing it's like I'm
enlightened when I open this thing it's
unbelievable let me tell you about Omaha
Steaks
for $49.99 you can get my family gift
pack when you go to their website and
search h3 in the search bar that's 75%
off this is high-quality meets my
friends for $49.99 listen to what you
get two filets of the mignons I knew a
guy who once said fill it MIG nons here
in Australia he was Australia apparently
that's what they call it in Australia
but I didn't know that I'm sitting at a
restaurant with this guy he goes I'll
have a Phillip MIG not I'm like might be
you're not people aren't that dumb
if you're that uncultured you don't
deserve a filet mignon meghna hon I
thought was funny Phil it may not you
get to fill at Megan ons you get two
tops
two boneless pork chops four boneless
chicken breast for kielbasa sausages
hold on let me catch my breath
four burgers for potato a Bratton's
which is yeah these are actually you
look me is incredible the potatoes are
good I'm not gonna take that away from
it's a huge potato ball that's like it's
like mashed potato in a ball it's like
who made what genius made this you get
four of those four caramel apple Titan
to our new list one OMA steak seasoning
pack and plus in addition because they
love you and because I love you you get
four additional kale bosses say it with
me because it's a lot of fun to say
kielbasa sausage is absolutely free on
top of that you get all of that for
$49.99 that's 75% off by going to Omaha
Steaks dot-com and in the search bar
type h3 and you'll find my family gift
pack Omaha's got over 500 gourmet gift
ideas they got great steak experiences
at home the most flavorful tender aged
beef plus seafood poultry pork veal lamb
veggies dessert appetizers pasta soup
seasoning they're basically just listing
everything they've got it all in in
short convenient shopping guys it's for
those on your list ages it's aged for 21
days to unlock the full flavors of the
cuts hand trim vacuum-sealed my friends
you are not gonna want to miss this h3
family pack so head on over to Omaha
Steaks comm enter my code h3 in the
search bar and get 20 75 % savings
unheard of you're gonna love this
I guarantee it Thank You omaha
appreciate you and your steaks thank you
to lift for sponsoring this episode a
stream podcast lift knows that their
drivers it is what keeps them moving
literally so they do everything they can
to make sure their drivers are happy on
every trip it's a simple formula dry
happy drivers mean happy passengers
maybe that's why 9 out of 10 lyft
drivers get a perfect five-star rating
are they I don't know
can take credit for that I think the
drivers are just nice but I guess it's a
nice environment right I mean I don't
know you can take credit for I mean you
know people helping people right you're
gonna meet interesting people you can
have chat if you want to be a writer you
want to be an artist a creative hopping
a lift and drive some rad you're gonna
learn a lot of things people give you 5
stars you can be happy about yourself
give me confidence ok but you know
forget all that because you can earn
hundreds of dollars a week plus tips
want to earn more money drive more it's
never been easier to give yourself a
raise lift was the first rideshare
platform with tipping built right in
ok and so because getting tips shouldn't
depend on your passenger having a
crumpled bill in his pocket and let me
just say to their credit I completely
agree I never have I prefer riding lifts
because I can tip through the app and I
don't carry cash
hello I only carry Bitcoin right
does lyft accept Bitcoin I don't
understand cryptocurrency you can't use
it no I've just I don't get it ok you
can't use it how are the currency it's
like the monopoly money you keep 100% of
the tips and they add up quick as hack
my friends drivers have been paid over
200 million dollars since this feature
was first introduced express pay lets
you get paid almost instantly
except waiting for weeks and hope maybe
not even getting paid at all by these
scumbag employers out there you know got
to deal with that when you drive for a
lift lift has taken the guesswork out of
pickups the new amp device uses color
coding to help passengers find their
drivers guys so listen up join the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better go to lift
calm slash h3 today and you will get a
$500 new driver bonus that's 500 clams
for a new driver bonus that's
lyft ly ft.com / h3 lifts calm / h3
limited time only and terms to apply so
thank you to lift for sponsoring us if
you're in the market for if you try to
pick up some money consider supporting
us with lyft and if you want some ding
meets please consider supporting us with
no mistakes thank you so much for
watching let's get back into the socks
and we're back HD podcast with Vsauce
what you did you ever consider puking
out the ayahuasca after you drink it
were you like can I do that yeah you
don't have time as soon as it's entered
your body you can try to vomit it up but
some DMT has already entered your
bloodstream oh you would reduce the
effect if you just like gagged maybe
yeah
I mean you would have to be the case
rheya rough start vomiting and diarrhea
argh
or not not diarrhea but like lots of
pooping could be solid I'm assuming is a
big part of the ayahuasca experience you
know and it's um how nice something
they're prepared for I had a puke bucket
there there are bathrooms there they
captured never happened never have I
ever even felt like I had an upset
stomach and I've heard of shaman who
encouraged that it's part of the process
of kind of abusing yourself and there
could be a legitimate medical reason
that it's good in that you can flush out
harmful bacteria if you really are
having some intestinal problems but
never happened to me some some shaman
will make you puke by either
disorienting you with their song or
giving you a tobacco drink but that
could be pretty dangerous I mean we did
this as safely as possible again we had
a medical doctor there you don't play
yeah yeah and so I think that's a huge
lesson to learn like this was not a
recreational let's have fun in a weird
kind of a moment this was a let's work
with a university let's work with a
hospital and let's let's learn what was
the scientific purpose of the I know you
did you put the electrode things on yeah
on your head to measure your brain with
it was that the purpose or was it just
to go through this experience as a
science scientist of sorts and to try to
describe it it was both because I wanted
to see if I could help it talk about
that state of mind as someone who's a
professional science communicator but at
the same time no study had been done
that was that environmentally valid like
literally done in the Amazon with those
songs in those languages in that
location they're usually done in these
very clinical hospital and
where you're in a white room and you
don't know you're in a big city right so
we were able to look at that and help
the researchers learn what variables to
worry about what kind of technology
works obviously it's not an experiment
it's not like oh we had a whole sample
size in a control group it's just one
person you've got an N of one drops
pretending
yeah we're not pretending that this is
some experiment it was more of a kind of
pilot study to see what is it like to go
to these retreats and try to collect
data mm can we find anything interesting
is this particular EEG helmet gonna give
us enough data or is it too noisy and
all of that so we learned a lot in that
case I felt a little bit cocked eased by
that experience because you guys were
saying in the show you did it the first
time you took a small dose the second
time we took a larger dose and you guys
were saying I almost had a ego day I
know I wasn't almost there yeah
I didn't quite get there yeah then I was
like oh great well I can't wait for the
third one when he gets there right now I
know that way there's only three minutes
left I know what happened that's what
happens when you are doing it for real
and you you you you don't know what the
results gonna be you know we have a lot
did you consider doing it again though
cuz you could have taken more I you know
yeah I could have decided cuz a few
hours in that second ceremony I realized
who you know what I can't get back to
that ceiling that I was afraid of and
turned away from I could have gotten up
and asked for more this can happen
during a ceremony but I didn't and there
are other things that you'll see in
future episodes where like I tried to
get TMS on my head to disrupt and arrest
my speech we could not find Broca's area
they couldn't make it happen hmm that's
just what happens you know if we'd spent
muscle was the dose was the large dose
you took what is normally enough to have
someone have like a full ego loss I
think it's different person to person
depends on your weight depends on your
mindset depends on the setting you know
a full cup is pretty strong but you know
the point of ayahuasca is not to
experience ego death it's it's different
person-to-person like for a lot of
people a small dose it's just to kind of
like I don't know whatever effect do you
think it's you know you want from it
right it's not about your doing well if
you're taking more not at all hmm not at
all you continued down the rabbit hole
of strange drugs later in the season and
you experimented with the truth serum to
see if an interrogator who gives you
this truth serum can actually get
information out of you
I was actually surprised by how
effective in my opinion it was like you
you just shoot the interrogation
technisches was very clever right like
it's not what you expect like in the
movies you have like a Bond villain
who's like and you just get brainwashed
and say everything but the way she
approached it was very clever yeah it
was clever and it was really fun like I
just felt like I am the most funny
person ever right now so I'm just gonna
give you materia and she she yeah didn't
play bad cop and I think at one point I
asked her to you know I was like hey
could you stop being so nice right um I
don't remember that I don't remember
much after I think when she asked me who
the president was they kept giving you
more there like him a little bit you're
like I'm pretty [ __ ] up and like
tomorrow I was like dad thank you Father
funny moment where the guy's a sadist
out you know this is this is more than I
I'm not gonna give any more when I was
like I could take more and but I don't
remember it that was the scary part it
was that they could have told me I had
said anything and I wouldn't know if
they were wrong or not right and the
thing about midazolam which is the truth
serum that I was administered is that
there's an antidote forest that works
quite quickly really so all of a sudden
I just come to and I'm like away I
always wondered if that was possible it
was weird it was like just to go from
completely [ __ ] to sober I find that
yeah I didn't know how much time had
passed I just immediately was like hey
Wow mmm what happened and I was forming
memories again all of a sudden huh yeah
but the so the way that she got in for
the game
was that you had information you're
trying to conceal from her she was
trying to get it like for example that
you had a sister I guess was one of them
yeah and my sister's name your sister's
name so her approach wasn't to be like
tell me your sister's name like you
would exceed in a movie it's what like
she would wait to your super smashed and
be like so your sister jessica is a
dentist for a living and then you would
be like yeah that's what you you know
you like it's really clutch really
tricky you had to really be sharp and
you had to not just be living in the
moment to keep the information they
basically just dull your brain to the
point of you're just agreeable well yeah
all your inhibitions are gone yeah
you're not holding anything back because
you're it's not aware of what you should
be holding back you're just living in
that exact moment where there's nothing
else to be concerned about right it's
like the puppy-dog mode you thinking
about a little puppy
he's a truth serum all the time what do
you what do you think after doing that
do you think that that serum is is it an
effective way to get information from
someone I think that it is an effective
way to get information I don't think
it's an ethical way right and I should
with the caveat that I don't I'm not
sure it's effective because studies that
were real studies not just Michaels
experience have shown that you get some
pretty unreliable stuff people will say
all kinds of lies as well sure did you
lie at all during it mm-hmm um no I
didn't really lie I told obvious jokes
but I don't like I can't I can't see
lying in that state of mind but you know
she's unreliable it was hard to it was
hard to construct a lie that I knew was
a lie but I maybe could have or someone
as has been shown in prior studies they
can confabulate all kinds of made ups
just like a dreamlike state or you're
just following some random thread in
your head there's also the ethical
dilemma of can a person be forced to
confess against themselves sure right if
if what you have to do is torture
someone or administer drugs
intravenously to get the truth is that
really the way we want to get the truth
what's more important and ever since the
days of torture you know
we've been a hey you cannot
self-incriminate if we have to resort to
that it's not worth it and there's
something kind of beautiful about that
yeah totally
oh it's completely unethical I just
found it with it's really interesting to
see because truth serum always seems
like something which is ridiculous like
how does that how could that possibly
exist yeah but that real-world
application of it it was like oh that
makes sense
yeah I mean truth serum is a terrible
names it makes it seem like sorry
fictional sci-fi drug like mine was the
truth right in reality it just pretty
makes it harder to conceal in life right
exactly
I think the most interesting thing that
you confess to well on the truth serum
is that you prefer making Vsauce videos
to minefield yeah I had looked right out
I had no memory that ever happening it
wasn't until I was one of our writers
was like driving me home date like
months later and he was like oh cuz I
wasn't supposed to know what I'd said
because if they wanted me to watch the
footage back on camera and he spilled
you watch the whole thing back watch the
whole thing back yeah and you were
really genuine the interrogators like
Michael do you prefer doing Vsauce or
minefield and you're like you were just
very passionately in favor of Vsauce
yeah you know in the show and I felt I
felt bad cuz you know if I hadn't have
been under the effects of midazolam I
would have given a more diplomatic
diplomatic answer but you know I think
you know the truth should be out there
now I love making minefield but as you
can imagine minefield has a deadline
it's got schedules it's got you know
sauce it comes out when it when it comes
out when I'm ready I thought it was a
great moment because it really
exemplified how unguarded you were yeah
totally was there anything else in that
interrogation you don't have to tell me
what it was but I was curious was there
anything else you said during that where
you're like oh [ __ ] I can't believe I
said that
no okay no and so when I saw the
original cut is again I'm not I'm not
editing minefield episodes but I'm
watching and we're screening episodes so
I'll see one like four times throughout
the editing process but
usually notes you don't involved in that
a bunch of notes and then no they're
doing the Edit over the shoulder yeah
but I remember watching the first cut
and going we got to include more of the
truth serum experience and so I got the
all the footage watched all of it and
made notes and I was like don't include
all of this like even if it's not
scientific data it's still interesting
yeah so the stuff that we cut because
you have to cut for time that's sure
bummer like the whole thing to read for
two minutes well why don't they care
about time I think audiences care about
time because the if you show the whole
experience all of a sudden the whole
episode becomes three hours long so we
have bonus clips this season which allow
us to show more like when it came to
false confessions I was like we have to
include a raw uncut false confession
right because even though there's a
whole lot of stuff that we can cut for
time like just the pleasantries the
hellos the conversations that go nowhere
I want someone I want everyone to be
able to see beginning to end how it
happens how you get a regular person to
confess to a crime they never admitted I
am horrified by that yeah and well I
think a lot of people have seen the
documentary to make making of murder
yeah and it wasn't the main guy's story
that disturbed me honestly it was his
cousin yeah brand-new yeah Brandon who
went to prison he just got out this year
he was thrown out by a federal judge he
was in prison for 12 years and the prime
of his life you see him now he's like
this grizzled like shell of a person who
lost the prime of his life
the guy is mentally handicapped I mean I
you can tell throughout he's like a
simpleton he's like Lenny from my should
not have been interrogated
he shouldn't his yeah and so these cops
are grilling him and grilling him
grilling him for hours and hours and
hours how the like having been through
that you're yourself and having produced
it and how do these police or people who
do this how do they justify it to
themselves because certainly people
don't just think of themselves as evil
or wrong like in their minds as
completely justified that's a incredibly
important point that very few people on
earth are like you know what
I mean I really like Captain Planet
villains right yeah to be mean instead
everyone's different but you know you
might think look this person is a bad
apple
you know they've maybe committed crimes
in the past they're going to continue to
whether or not they committed this
particular crime doesn't matter let's
just get them off the streets right so
the motivation feels like good
intentions right but it does a
disservice to our society when we aren't
getting the truth when we don't get
reliable information right it's
disturbing to think how many people are
probably in prison right now due to
false confession it's the second most
common reason people are falsely
convicted of crimes number one is
eyewitness testimony that's a whole
other that's a fantasy yeah yeah yeah I
just the justice system really surprised
me sometimes and whenever you hear I was
watching another one of these true
detective oh there's a whole documentary
on Netflix really so about yeah and it's
I had to turn it off I watched one
episode and I was like man this ended
awfully yeah like there was no just
there was no vindication it just ended
like and now he's in prison and he's
been there for 20 years it's like wall
all right yeah so I don't remember the
name of that documentary but I so
recommend it because it's got multiple
episode and you find that because you
see that the reasons all these different
people falsely confessed are completely
different in some cases it's that you
know the guy just drank a lot and would
often black out and didn't remember what
he had done and just became convinced
that he must have in other cases it's
well how can a lie detector be wrong
like I was shopping with my friend but
the lie detector says that I killed my
daughter so by the way the confession
tapes is what it's called an infection
tapes must-watch I don't know if we
ain't even introduced this what we're
talking about but you did an episode on
false confessions correct
and the way that you got that one girl
to confess it's like you guys
manipulated her like very intentionally
and perfectly but seeing it happen just
makes you realize like how [ __ ] Howie
Howie
you can have because it's always easy to
think like like why would they confess
if I didn't do something I wouldn't
confess exactly right you you weren't
course it was assumed the person might
be kind of crazy or maybe they did
commit the crime how could how could a
otherwise healthy person confess and
it's manipulation yeah it's it's not
about coercion in the sense of like
force and meanness being the bad cop
there was no bad cop
no bad cops was this director who they
never met that could show up at any time
I'm the good cop and for half of the day
I was not getting false confessions
wasn't able to make it work so Melissa
who was the expert I said could you just
do the next participant funny enough it
wound up being someone who was a big
vsauce fan could not have been luckier
that the one person who knew vsauce was
not interrogated by me he probably would
have had to have called it off for that
participant but anyway it was about
being nice it was about being friends
with the person you're just showing them
that if you confess that's like
honestly the best thing because maybe
you don't who knows what could happen
look if you confess it's like a piece a
I get it it's just it's the best thing
for you in my opinion as someone who's
your friend and people's and eschewed as
you got this girl to sign this paper you
wrote out a paper saying like I cheated
on the exam and just sign and date it
and I'm in my mind and playing it
through my through my head the stories
I've heard of people who just signed
that paper so easily and then next thing
they know that the police come in with
handcuffs and they never leave prison
again for their whole lives
yeah and the the thing that struck stood
out to me about what you did too is how
much practice it took yes you don't you
that you don't just accidentally get
someone to falsely confess you have to
be an expert you have to be a
professional you have to be trained you
have to know exactly how to manipulate
people and so to me it I really it made
me hate those those Pig
you know but it made me like it's really
this it made me very frustrated to think
that there's people using these these
techniques for nefarious yeah processes
Melissa it's very it's very it's very
what's the word it's very conscious you
have to know exactly what you're doing
to do it yeah you do and again it's hard
to know what people's intentions are
often they're not bad instead it's like
I'm convinced you did it
yeah and now it's my job to get a
confession and it doesn't matter how I
get it it doesn't matter if I sort of
that's a shame that's that's it that
means there's something [ __ ] up in our
justice system where there's not more
emphasis on the truth yeah there's more
emphasis on Buchan Bucknam yeah I think
what we need is a better way to analyze
whether someone's telling the truth and
cooperating or not before the decision
is made that they're guilty time to get
that confession because once you have a
confession in a court looks pretty bad
yeah no matter what the evidence says if
you've confessed to the crime a murder
and a rape it's kind of a closed case
yeah it's done
so you know I I don't know all the
details of the legal system obviously I
was just interested in the psychology of
how do you get someone how to manipulate
someone in they're just saying you know
what I'd rather cooperate and do what
you say then stand up for what I really
did and the thing is how much time did
it take you to get that one girl to
falsely confess so it took her maybe 25
minutes because they spent on his cousin
Moses name Brandon Brandon yeah they I
think they spent like 12 hours with him
right now of course the difference there
is that he is being interrogated about a
very serious crime right whether or not
you exchange information and also had
ups meant exactly now we didn't include
another girl that I got a false
confession from and it took I I don't
know the exact number but it took like
nine minutes Wow
she was only 19 and the power dynamic
was incredibly skewed
and I when we debriefed her she was like
she literally said well I confessed cuz
you had all the power like what was I
gonna die already made you mad bye
apparently cheating hmm I wasn't gonna
say no to your request for me to sign a
data form and it just made me see she
was 19 which means her confession is a
signed confession from an adult right
but because of the she was the small
person and it just she was like how come
you didn't include that one it was again
about time and that's the biggest kind
of bummer about it made it look like you
only got it once yeah yeah and so I want
to use bonus clips to tell more of these
stories but one thing we've noticed in
season two is that the episodes contains
so much stuff like we should have just
done false confessions as an episode but
instead we fit lots of things in there
we had the p300 brain scanner we had
midazolam and so we couldn't say all
right now we're gonna spend 40 minutes
on interrogation and then after all of
that we're gonna switch gears again I
think that's a good idea and you have
more content to you can get for all
those all of those deserve yeah their
own episode yeah exactly so now I think
you know moving forward I would like to
focus on more seasons ahead uh well I
don't know I hope so okay a support
minefield of them and you know I I
understand it costs money but YouTube
bread really helps creators like myself
and shows like mine field be made so you
know I really want YouTube to see that
this is a good bet educational content
is popular it's gotta be one of the most
popular YouTube it's only when I watch
and my opinions only good one if I'm
being honest I mean not to throw salt
everyone has different tastes and I'm
excited to see what you know YouTube red
comes out with next what kind of
decisions they make about their original
program I don't know I don't understand
a strategy I don't understand you to
read but whatever that's a whole
different [ __ ] camera it's so
complicated I have to mate you know what
yeah I don't I don't need another
episode of me bitching about you
that's already like 20 of those but I am
curious what is it like I actually want
to ask you something else that the what
you did with the brain scanner yeah
where they could tell what you stole
I am very I don't like that [ __ ] yeah
and I don't like that [ __ ] the same as I
don't like lie detectors it's all a
bunch of crap and I hate it I hate those
I hate those machines and I hate people
who think bright can use it to tell the
truth right
that one was disturbing though do you
very district how do you fit do you
think that that would is it accurate
maybe you can describe what it was so
people know what we're talking so so a
typical lie detector is looking at skin
conductivity and things like that and
blood pressure blood pressure whatever
you mean it's a solo pseudoscience it's
not very reliable yeah yeah and it's
more about you know making the person
nervous enough that they feel like they
can't hide things but really what
happens is people who don't have
anything to hide feel like they're not
being believed and they start to not
believe themselves but we are if you're
a real psychopath you can just [ __ ]
if you believe it yeah George Costanza
season 7 episode 2 exactly however the
p300 doesn't fall for those problems
right what this does is it looks at how
your brain electrically responds to to
various stimuli and there's a response
called p300 that has to do with novelty
so if something is new to you you'll see
in effect but if you've seen something
before oh that's what it measures that's
what it does I thought I thought it was
measuring the familiarity and not the
not the novelty verka they're related
you know it's something like look if if
you really didn't commit this crime and
you've never been to the crime scene you
never would have seen this door and you
have no control at all over how your
brain would react to that image you you
you have no voluntary control over
whether you recognize something right
you can't show me picture my mom and
have me go no I'm not gonna turn on the
recognition switch it happens but it
sounds like there could be room for
mistakes to happen with something like
that well people have tried right the
you know and that's what I tried in the
episode I tried to like every time an
image showed up I tried to pretend like
there was something amazing I was just
breehn about it and it didn't make a
difference because again it's not this
simple a to be if there's this algorithm
in between that knows how to correct for
different strategies so it's not
accepted there's an algorithm see that
that's where I'm out I don't mind I
don't but like if the brain is actually
sending a signal I would buy that but if
they have a man-made algorithm that
reduces sure you are that I don't buy
right cuz then you wonder what's in
between
well the algorithms are fallible human
work is fallible if my brain shoots off
a signal every time I see something that
I recognize that's compelling right but
if this if these guys are you know I
don't know how they can make an you know
what you're saying I mean what their
algorithm tries to do is better read
that recognition signal and and get rid
of noise or other things you might be
trying to do like with a regular lie
detector if you you know clinch your
budget I'm they ask a question your
exactly but with this they they're
they're computers are are watching every
measure and they're able to detect when
you're trying so what do you think is
this a true lie detector that they've
developed I believe that it is the most
reliable truth detector out there that's
terrifying and it's terrifying and
that's why it's not accepted by any
court that's that's unethical a my
opinion exactly so so Craig stark
actually who was on the video games
episode he had I don't if I can say this
he's been involved in these kinds of
discussions like should a prosecution be
able to force someone to undergo a
functional MRI or any kind of brain
scanning lie-detector and they're two
two issues one is that if it is really
good maybe that's bad because maybe we
should be allowed to have privacy in our
own minds yes secondly if it's even if
there's a chance that it's not reliable
that it might have a wrong result a jury
is easily swayed by well I'm wearing a
lab coat and this they exhaust a million
dollars and said that you did the crime
what are you gonna do you're gonna
believe the science even if in reality
it could be fifty-fifty
I yeah they're I don't like you do you
need privacy in your own mind we can't
have this all-powerful machine that
knows when you're lying the social
implication of that is awful it's like a
dystopian future yeah and again there's
a chance that it's wrong you know there
is always a chance of something right
it's like the like what if there's a
door that I don't necessarily know but
maybe I've walked by that place oh yeah
exactly
sometime in my life that reminds me of
something oh it reminds me of this
machine it reminds me of that [ __ ]
Tom Tom Cruise movie was by Steven
Spielberg just don't be in future you
got it Minority Report Mike that it's
the Minority Report yeah so we have to
be really careful and I feel like yeah
we're gonna have more and more
discussions about this as the technology
improves and weirdly I think yeah we
might have to start saying that some
methods of learning some methods of
knowledge are off limits I I did an
episode on is all really fair in love
and war and I looked at the Geneva
Conventions I looked at things like um
you know is it not all countries have
this kind of a law but in the u.s. your
spouse cannot be compelled to testify
against you because in America there's
this feeling that if we have to ruin a
marriage to get the truth we shouldn't
get the truth because the marriage is
you know more important and there's a
lot of religious overtones there like
that marriage is under the umbrella of
God right and us determine whether you
embellish it embezzled these funds
that's our concern and if we can't prove
you did without ruining your marriage
then you're free yeah and not all
countries do that but there's something
very philosophically powerful about the
notion of if we can't we're not gonna go
after your family to find out what you
did it's the same with parents right
some states have the law where the
parents have to cooperate or they don't
if like their son for example is in
suspect of murder then in some states
the parents don't have to cooperate yeah
the cops I think it's I think it's great
I think there needs to be some things
more important than or not even that but
there needs to be some there needs to be
some boundaries right right and that
doesn't mean that there's no way to find
the truth like look for evidence
elsewhere but I think there are there
are other protections about privacy with
your attorneys with clergy
you know what I say in in this religious
context to a you know to a priest in in
a confession I should be free to have
that relationship and not withhold stuff
and keep it to myself because it could
be you know used against me right is
then where are we
mm-hmm was it worth it what was it like
working with YouTube executives because
you had expressed you know you preferred
Vsauce so let's just [ __ ] on YouTube a
little bit here no I'm kidding but how
what was it like having someone else
over your head I mean II Latoya the idea
of having a show yeah and I think I
underestimate how annoying or awful or
that that would be having someone all of
a sudden you've had creative control
your whole life and you've got some guy
over your head telling ya well you can't
can't do yeah we're all so spoiled by
the fact that we can make whatever kind
of contract you want as long as we're
not breaking laws right that's the way
it is sometimes it means that it's worse
because you should have taken someone
else's advice either other times it just
means that what you're making is more
authentically you I think that in this
season YouTube and and the production
company and myself and the whole crew we
got much much closer to understanding
what science community communication can
be and how to you know make the right
show I think that for all the
disagreements I'll have with YouTube
saying yeah that's boring and then I
think I think personally I'm probably a
bit too precious about we got to put
more facts more explanations more just
me talking about the thing I think when
you find the right balance you can reach
more people that would drive me crazy
some [ __ ] telling me that's boring
feel yourself getting like the righteous
sir not ever but like offensive right
like well [ __ ] are you it's not boring
it's my show
no one ever said anything was boring
it's good more like here's my concern
about this right and then it gives me a
chance to externalize why I think it's
important and that's valuable because
when it's just in your own head you
don't always know what your instincts
are telling you or how to vocalize them
but when you're forced to sit in front
of someone and say here's why I think
that you know we should release the
false confession with no edits yeah but
if you if you don't edit it there's
gonna be a lot of boring stuff I'm like
well but I'm not doing it for the views
I'm doing it for like look slice of it's
a human Zoo or watching you know and and
and by thinking that out and in
defending it yourself you're defending
yeah I'm gonna you're right you're a
real half glass full guy aren't ya there
you go yeah all right we come up on our
second break we've got tons more sauce -
v/o we'll take some questions yeah we
take some questions guys give us a ring
pop up the number was the number I read
it to you guys your revenge eight one
eight two one four eight five oh four
give us a call if you got some questions
for your boy Vsauce we'll be right back
after this commercial break
see you guys soon thank you to me undies
for sponsoring this episode of the H
Street podcast these guys make the best
underwear end of Perea end of period
wherever that means end of sentence if
you wear underwear you need me undies
it's that simple every year thank you
for showing tip you can I'll tell you
you could dip my uh you could dip my
Froot Loops and that milk if you know
what I mean no I like to dip my Froot
Loops in that milk anyway every year
millions people receive the least like
gift of all time underwear but we still
give it to our family loved ones who
don't want it because we hate them
that's not in there I added that but
maybe it's not the underwear that's the
problem
it's the kind of underwear let me tell
you about me undies it's the only
underwear that makes an amazing gift
because it's such an amazing product all
right
I love me undies because I've got a
swampy saturated Cho
it's hot in LA everyday it's December
15th today and it's like 90 degrees
normal underwear it doesn't cut it I
need something that's velvety soft
that's gonna absorb all my [ __ ]
flavors much like is much like is shown
here
it's a swampy milky fruit loopy place
and this is the undies that is equipped
and it's song it's so soft it's flexible
bro
trust me you think I'm memeing around
just try one pair and tell me it's not
the best with soft flexible waistband
three times softer than cotton naturally
sustain sourced fibers okay me undies
made underwear the perfect gift that
everyone's gonna love it's a goddamn
holiday miracle that there's an
underwear that can actually cradle my
supple child like ball sack why do you
have things it's shell like because it's
so supple not because of the size what
can I say I mean they can see this year
don't give underwear give me auntie
sorry now listen here because this
holiday season you get an exclusive 20%
off the softest underwear and socks you
will ever wear free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guaranteed go to me undies
dot-com / h3 that's me undies com / h3
thank you to me undies and thanks to
them just on it as a general note for
making such a wonderful place to rest my
jewels and finally thank you to our
sponsor honey do you want to save money
while shopping online for last-minute
holiday gifts well let me tell you about
an online shopping hack from a start-up
that I recently discovered called honey
they call it a hack I call I mean it's
yeah this one way to refer to it you
could also call it a plug or a plug in
you know a browser plug-in it's a
browser plug it's not really a hack you
installed that you're a hacker I'm a hat
bro I hacked I hacked my way too much
through the internet and saved a bunch
of I'm kid about that but the product
itself is incredible let me tell you
about the product honey
was founded by two friends who were
frustrated by the lack of price
transparency from online shopping so
they started honey to help others find
the best possible prices online here's
how it works
honey is a free 100 percent free browser
extension for Chrome Firefox Safari it
effortlessly saves you time and money
while shopping online at tens of
thousands of stores you guys know how
easy it is to install a plugin you
literally just type honey Chrome if
that's we use you click once it's in its
it's easy as pie eating a pie I think
most people have a easy time eating pie
I'm sure there's some people there's
generally it's easy it's eating pie
feels like moving on just saying I just
want to clarify that so while you shop
honey will instantly find every working
coupon code on the internet and
automatically apply the best discount to
your cart at checkout Time magazine
called it basically free money and
hackers magazine called it the alt the
best hack of 2017
that's actually illegal in some states
because I'll tell five life hacks it's
yeah it's a definitely top five it's not
illegal by the way I'm that was a total
joke that's perfectly legal to use it is
a hack though honey makes Amazon better
this is a really important part and this
is what the most that I loved about it
so you install this plugin I use Amazon
all the freakin time
but it's pretty it can be sometimes
annoying to navigate and sometimes it
idles can be sold by other sellers who
have Amazon Prime for example and it's
like 10 20 bucks cheaper then then
what's the default that you land on and
so what honey will do on Amazon is that
it's gonna sort the best option from
different sellers automatically
factoring out all the variables such as
price shipping costs prime status and so
the more so you basically you're always
gonna get the best price and the best
experience and I've or I've been using
this for months and frankly has been a
huge it's already saved me a lot of
money at random stores at checkout it's
like boom coupon applied it's like oh my
god basically free money but Amazon very
useful it will find you the deals
effortlessly
okay capiche honey can also show you the
price trend of any item because it's
always changing the prices always
changing on Amazon who can keep up with
this stuff so you know if it's the best
time to buy it Black Friday and Cyber
Monday may be over but you can still
save money this Christmas with honey
honey I just installed I just hacked
your computer installed honey thanks
honey honey as always has already saved
over hundreds of millions of dollars
with over 6 million members it's
completely free to join and it will
literally only take you two clicks to
start saving money guys you got nothing
to lose give it a shot it's you're gonna
love it
go to honey calm /h 3 that's join oh
sorry guys it's join honey calm / h3
join honey calm / h3 go to that link so
they know that we sent you thank you so
much - honey appreciate you guys if
you're in the market for a life hack err
or you know some soft blushes underwear
please consider supporting the show
thank you guys let's get back to sauce
time welcome back everybody to the h3
podcast with Vsauce talking again about
we were talking about YouTube executives
before was there anything they vetoed or
got in the way of creatively during the
making of the show that did stuck out to
you um I'm trying to remember oh yeah I
think I can tell this story because it
did it makes them look good like I
really wanted to be waterboarded uh-huh
that was going to be an episode I'll
watch that yeah and we found people who
were willing to waterboard me there I'm
sure they were lined up yeah they were I
mean I was I would only feel safe doing
it in that way that you've seen other
people have done this where you've got
people there who know what's going to
happen and you you have an immediate off
switch from what I've seen it's like
you're holding a big metal bar oh if you
let go of it
and it hits the floor it's loud it rings
and they immediately unhinge you I know
there was there was like this
conservative reporter who was like I'll
get waterboarded that she was in torture
I forget his name but I he got
waterboarded and he was like he sat up
immediately and is like that's torture
there's no question about it immediately
yep so it's different than like being
physically hurt you know
splinters up your fingernails because
you can you become numb to that kind of
pain like your body releases whatever it
is hormones or chemicals that allow you
to kind of like the the next one hurts
less the next one hurts less but when it
comes to elevated co2 in your blood
there's no mechanism for adapt like it's
not that bad it gets it's it's bad all
the time and it's it's much more
psychologically damaging it's not
physically dangerous unless you're
administering it poorly as I understand
it it's just like if shouldn't I don't
think you you don't die yeah you don't
really have any marks and unless the
restraints were too tight and that's
what makes it so nefarious you just feel
like you're drowning right you feel like
you're about to die because you don't
have you have too much co2 in your blood
you're not getting enough oxygen you
can't why is that I mean how does that
work by just dumping water over your
face well your face is completely
covered in this cloth and you're like
you can't draw in air and then we have
this reflex to water because we've
evolved to know that we we are not water
creatures and so you have a panic reflex
to that I can't breathe this I cannot
live like this that is very different
from being whipped or being punched
repeatedly it's a different kind of
torture like a pure panic yeah but you
so they administer it for just enough
time they let you breathe how does it
work that you can keep because clearly
you can keep breathing because you don't
die yeah you you know you're only unable
to breathe for seconds but it doesn't
take long for that panic instinct to
come in where you realize not only am I
not breathing but I'm at water is all
around me and it's in my mouth
and
um it well you only need a couple of
seconds and that panic happens and you
can't do it any longer okay so what
happened with the executives oh they
just thought that it was way too
dangerous and new and it was the scary
thing about waterboarding is how easy it
is to do it's not like well first of all
you have to get you know permission from
the FBI to handle you know c4 it's like
no you just do you have a water some
oregano in it yeah are you a bad person
here right it's like just do it that up
yeah yeah so um I think it was really
smart to say let's not do that
do you wish you did it though looking
back I mean it would have been
interesting that's the one what was the
scientific purpose of getting
waterboarded the purpose was to talk
about what I've just said which is the
sort of physiology of why it's different
from repeatedly being whipped or being
just just confined yes that that sort of
reflex we have to water is not good
around my mouth and covering all of my
ways of breathing and I could have just
discussed that but you know minefield
gives me a chance to do things right the
question is what do we gain by having me
undergo it and then say yep I can
confirm that one of the worst things you
can do to a person is indeed bad right
yeah and watching it may be too much
like if I'm trying to thank myself but
it wouldn't be like to watch you go
through it you don't bit too much
exactly and it that was a question we
had which is that we don't want to just
do things for the sake of like boy this
will be dramatic and good news so we try
to figure out what do you do while I'm
being waterboarded that contributes to
scientific knowledge and you know you go
to like the obvious I don't know put an
EEG net on your head and it's like what
so you can see panic like we already
know yeah so it turned out to just also
not be educational or interesting just
to see just juicy dangerous yeah that
sounds like ratings to me boom you seem
dangerous there you go
can I ask what's the budget on a show
like yours um per episode I don't know
the per episode budget I mean I'll tell
you that it cost more money to make
season 2 then Vsauce has I mean I could
have not paid anyone for a year and
still not made season 2 that's why I had
to work with YouTube you know they made
it possible
millions yeah yeah yeah we're not
talking about like well Michael why
didn't you just take out your debit card
and give me a season two please yeah and
and then give it to us all for free or
with AD support mm-hmm I was like this
is only possible only possible to build
a team working on educational content
like this if you got money cuz they
deserve to be paid for their time sure I
couldn't do it on my own yeah how long
does it take to film each episode how
long did it take to film the entire
season
we filmed through parts of four months I
had VidCon and a trip to London in there
but took a long time after ayahuasca it
was smooth sailing I wasn't so anxious
about like what was coming up yeah
and then we do all the rooftop scenes in
a week you know we were six days that
week like 6 p.m. to 6 a.m. you know
sunset to sunrise and that's pretty
weird
you flip in your whole day so it took
about 4 months of constant shooting to
film the whole season yeah and then the
whole time I was on the spring bring
handy to where we were in pre-production
so I would have these long hours and
hours long conference calls running
through ideas working with psychologists
on what can we do have we heard back
from that university yet can get this
person on board then of course you've
got all the editing the screening the
watching the episodes the notes then the
voice-over and then you're finally
locked and then you wait for the
ingestion process of getting captions
getting them approved getting them rated
and then getting them available on on
YouTube so that's your process yeah yeah
compared to that how long does it take
to research film and edit an episode of
Vsauce I mean it takes weeks as well it
can take months you know in its bits but
it's up to me when I feel like it's done
when I feel like I've got
deep enough in the explanation like
right now I'm working on a thing about
the center of mass and the center of
gravity and and how things rotate and
I'm just not happy until I've gotten to
a point where like the explanation is
say purely geometric no there's no more
like but why but why it's like because
we live in a universe with these
dimensions hmm there you go
and so yeah it takes a long time but
it's it's not like it takes a long time
because I'm just busy with mine field or
with brain candy or with the curiosity
box it takes a long time because I've
decided that I want it to be that runt I
want to put that much work into it right
I think that's I'm kind I'm jealous of
that mindset that you have and I know
there's other channels on YouTube to
have this it's done when it's done cuz I
get so anxious when I don't well they
have a whole different it's letting you
be doing educational content because I
can keep going deeper into the subject
right but if I was doing like comedy
like wins a joke done yeah is no answer
there's no definite answer do you get
anxious when you don't upload on V Sun
like a like a classic video oh yeah of
course yeah of course and I really start
feeling that pressure and I really feel
like you know if I if I'm not active
enough then people move on maybe they
stop even remembering that there's this
great thank you I think that I'm making
minute and so you know I can use social
media to put more out and the question
is like do I create a format like a type
of show that takes less work you know
like I could easily I could I could do
you know an episode about something just
from reading a Wikipedia page but I
wouldn't be happy with that it wouldn't
challenge me so I put a lot of time into
things and I try to consume all the
media that already exists on that top
and so I can say look I've read all the
books I've watched all these lectures
and here's the synthesis of them here's
what some of them missed out on some of
them added and so it it did justifies
its existence it's not just another of
the same hmm interesting tell me about
this was one from the subreddit
people were interested in tell me about
Michael Vsauce from middle school and
high school what kind of dude were you
then oh man
what was your lower education experience
I think that's lower education middle
school high school I mean I was still
the same person right now but I you know
there was no YouTube um I did all the
things you would expect right I was part
of the trivia team I I did act in a lot
of musicals and plays and stuff and I I
find that interesting that you're you
are an entertainer I feel like yeah as
much as you are an educator yeah which
one do you think you're more of an
entertainer huh I think it's just
important for me not to say like I'm
scientist Michael because I'm not and I
don't want anyone to think that I
believe I have super knowledge or any
kind of like I don't I mean the more
episodes I make the more I'm like I'm an
idiot and thank goodness that are such
smart people out there I can talk to so
you know I think it's just safer to be
an entertainer mmm science communicator
but what I'm pointing to and you can see
by the length of my video descriptions
look at what the researchers have done
look at what they're doing they're the
ones whose work I'm showing to the
public and helping them show to the
public what kind of plays were you in in
high school uh I was the oldest looking
student okay so when identical yeah
right in hell why high school I already
had a receding hairlines and so they
needed a dad Michael like yes you were
the typecast dad yeah I was the general
and Kiss Me Kate because I was the
oldest looking person right I had that
does the authority right did you have a
beard back then no I'm mm I had sideburn
very nice I'd like to say that I made
played around with the goatee I
definitely did and through college I had
a goatee okay it wasn't until I
graduated college moved to New York and
that was like right when the hipster
sort of subculture emerged
right like I was there with Williamsburg
and all of this and all of a sudden the
beard was totally of course you should
have a beard did you ever bleach her
nope that's a question I should never
all
I guess I rush to my tips once I loved
it I loved it you looked great no no you
didn't actually
Oh what are you talking about you didn't
know me then you're talking about that
I'm talking about this boy band
the boy band you did it not ironic oh
when I was in middle school and my hair
where'd you grow up I grew up in Ventura
okay yeah of course
so yeah you're like you know offspring
and crazy taxi in frosted tips yeah
thanks you're giving me a break here
you're you're letting me off the hook
it was the society around yeah it was
very popular at the time but as you can
imagine there's all these cool slick
kids where all the girls one of these
guys they all the girls I don't know
what it is they love the spiky frosted
tips
yeah all I wanted was some spiky frosted
tips
yellow what is what is it about the
soprano b44 look but anyway back in high
school
man I hate my [ __ ] hair but I wanted
to look like these cool frosted tips
gentlemen and I try to frost my curly
ass hair and it just really I looked
like I looked like a Three Stooges are
something like it was just a total
[ __ ] disaster
is that is that good hindsight or at the
time was it cool it was bad all that I
really yeah I hated my hair so much as a
kid my mom's a hairdresser and once
because my hair used to be quite long I
had like a full-on Jew fro down here
yeah and she straightened it I swear to
you now she's chemically straighten my
hair and I came and even then it
wouldn't fall I was like I'm gonna have
like a baffle made of hair right yeah it
was it just went like this Wow
like see photos bro it was humiliating
and it was chemically straightened so I
couldn't undo it right right yeah I I I
had curly hair as well and so I couldn't
do the looks that I wanted you know did
you wish you had frosted - no did you
want a spike I wanted the really gelled
look right you know some curly guys pull
off the gel look I never can
I probably didn't have and I didn't care
enough I didn't put and how would I even
do it I'm 31
okay so we're from the same generation
yeah got it
I'm older than you is that strange how
much that's strange not by the minds but
it's still strange because you stopped
the dad vibe
well yeah great hair yes that's true
they didn't help my case I'm gonna
bleach those I'm gonna take care of it
is funny to realize that like touring
with Adam Savage who is 50 right that we
gotta come across like which is the same
age I totally agree at a certain point
like past I'd say it 20 I want to say
like 20 is there I know some people who
are 22 that I consider my complete and
utter peers yeah but that's um yeah it's
really definitely not but over the age
of like 30 it's pretty much all the same
[ __ ] yeah some look older but yeah you
just become an adult you're just in this
yeah Locke yeah life sucks for all of us
we all have way too much responsibility
why do you think people are did you know
Jordan Pearson no anyway he's this guy
he's a he's a brain guy he's a
psychologist
he's a psychoanalyst or psycho
anesthetist I was one I was talking
about why is it that he thinks that so
many people are depressed these days
because it seems to me do you have that
same impression that there's more people
with mental more people with mental
health issues now then then there seem
to be before maybe it's an issue of
reporting or people more comfortable
talking about it but his explanation
that I thought was really compelling was
that life is more complicated now for an
individual than it was ever intended to
be or ever was before
what do you mean I'm just curious what
are your thoughts on that
that's a great question and I'm
completely unqualified to talk yeah sure
but life being more complicated I'm not
sure what that means but you have so
much knowledge
are not knowledge but like so much
information available to you it's an
overload to me it felt like we have so
many more responsibilities we have to go
work we have to take care of people we
have to pay bills we have to worry about
making money we have to worry about
having an apartment like all these stuff
but the one you'll have to worry about
government you have to worry about
taxation I mean naturally you don't you
just have like a [ __ ] farm that you
till right you just feed yourself I mean
shelter yourself feeding yourself
surviving off of the land is also pretty
complicated let me ask you this have you
ever read the Unabomber is manifesto I
live it I wouldn't recommend living it
but you know I I'm not afraid to admit I
ordered it off Amazon yeah and you know
his his theory by the way can I just say
it's like god Bless America that you can
buy that book yeah you know I think it's
it's such a weird thing when you get the
book it's got this whole disclaimer on
the back that's like no funds go to the
Unabomber like all the funds are donated
at the Red Cross and the publisher just
to cover the costs right but it's cool
that we can preserve that and not just
burn it and be like this was a he like
now let's hear what these guys these
going on the blow up some schools right
Mike no it's not okay the uncomfortable
thing about the Unabomber is that he had
a lot of the same philosophies that
futurists do today except that he mailed
bombs to people I have words that
disconnect everything yeah I think you
know the disconnect was that he believed
the only solution was a revolution that
completely tore down society okay he
goes so far as to say we need to destroy
and burn technical manuals books this is
all based on you know this is an idea we
hear all the time that like we evolved
for millions of years to deal with a
certain kind of society in life and then
rapidly in the last just hundreds of
years or less we've had
go into a whole different kind of living
that our biological bodies and minds
weren't I guess that's what well Jordan
bits writer cement and and what the
Unabomber says which I'm glad to be
quoting now let's put him on yeah he's
like look if if you he asked this good
question which is if you had to spend
every day fighting for your survival
finding food hunting building structures
reproducing if that was and you had to
do this all these creative challenging
ways every day and that was it just to
not die hmm would you still want to
check Twitter would you still want to
study the motions of the moon
yeah like are those really giving humans
happiness or is it a thing that we've
invented to fill the time should we now
have because we've invented agriculture
and we don't have to worry about food
and survival instead we can study the
physics of ceramic we can do all these
other things and those those aren't the
I forget what he calls them but they're
not these true goals so his opinion is
that arts and science is bad yeah yeah I
mean he was he was easel is that just I
mean I'm like argument that you
Unabomber here like defending him but
that just seems stupid because I mean
you can just go living on a [ __ ] farm
if you want to and that's what he did
right you know I mean he's still I think
had to buy certain things that he could
not get for himself I think he didn't
make a lot of his own clothing but his
whole argument was that look look at the
car okay the car was invented and it's
more than an invention though it is
something that we now have to deal with
because think of how many people live in
a place where they need a car just to
get to work or to some family yeah again
that's what it's like you have to buy a
car insurance you get home it shares all
this [ __ ] you have to feel right so
technology isn't just lawless balonus a
technology is a thing that changes us
and all of a sudden now we've got cars
we have roads you're not free to go
wherever you want to go actually you
used to be you could just walk wherever
now ooh the highways it's actually you
know you can't walk there no pedestrians
right and and you know a lot of this is
at least philosophically interesting
I don't prescribe to his philosophy yeah
I think that it's worth considering
these I I there's a great wired article
called the future doesn't need us and in
that article the author quotes the
Unabomber without crediting him and you
read this section you go that's really
amazing that like we're reaching a point
where we can't turn off the technology
because our lives depend on it and then
later in the article he's like by the
way that was the Unabomber you're like
whoa you know and that's what actually
spurred me to get the book because I
wanted to see this and it is fascinating
to think what I've evolved to be able to
do to spread my genes all happened
before the internet before telephones
before agriculture before tools and now
this technology is here and it's you
know it's affecting us yeah definitely I
I've always felt that like evolution has
isn't really taking form in humans it's
more the the technology is our evolution
like we were fighting natural evolution
because if someone's born with a birth
defect we we help them survive someone
who's like we we we coddle or that I see
what you're saying people are being
eliminated from the gene pool like what
would happen in the wild I guess is what
you say natural selection is stopped
controlled by us yeah and I think
there's incredibly great arguments for
why it is important hey you're not you
you have trouble getting around this can
help you that's fantastic yeah there's
there's this much more abstract question
of because we invented the container
it's all gone hill downhill yeah like
because we could start collecting more
berries than we needed for that day
we all of a sudden lost this cycle that
we have to go through psychologically of
finding a challenge and overcoming it
right all of a sudden it's like well I
don't need to do any of this stuff to
live yeah but I've got the time so I'm
gonna go to and do a nine-to-five job or
I'm going to you know learn how to
juggle or I'm going to and those all are
great but the the perspective that do
they make us happy
I get really deep I genuinely think that
part of the reason why people are so
depressed or anxious or whatever is the
lack of like fundamentally and
biologically fulfilling things like
growing [ __ ] or raising a child or have
like these things I really build
building a shelter stuff like that yeah
that like our brains are wired to
actually be satisfied when you do
something like that and we don't have
that level of satisfaction by going to a
nine-to-five job and getting a check and
picking up groceries like you don't get
that same sense of purpose from these
things fulfillment I think is that key
word yeah you know you said that and a
it's weird to imagine that question that
I that I you know posed earlier which is
that if every day was about will I be
able to find enough food and clean water
to survive and but I can I'm able to do
that but it takes up all of my time and
cognitive resources and creativity every
day would I still do X mmm would I still
you know and and it's weird because are
you arguing that we shouldn't have
explored the world or invented the
printing press or poetry right the
Unabomber would say yeah that's bad and
I hate the cliche oh there's a balance
that we need but I think that it's
something we're going to be asking
ourselves more and more and well-run
evitable it's like you can't fight
progress it's like can you the Unabomber
believed he could not I feel like I work
out what he thinks is he's going back to
a natural state but I would argue it's
unnatural to fight the progress right
we're having yeah this is this and I
think what were we're undergoing is is
natural because our brains evolved to be
able to realize hey
I can make this stone a bit sharper and
everything happenings natural yes it's
all we're all playing out like the
natural course of how a species like
ours evolved and at my point about
natural selection no longer taking place
is that we're no longer being selected
on a biological like I think in a
thousand years if we're still around
we're gonna be the same species but the
technology is now what's replaced
biological evolution is a technological
evolution yep
might it be that in the future thousands
tens of thousands of years from now
natural selection will have selected
people who don't get so stressed out and
depressed by technology's influence on
the world because you just if you don't
fit into the mold of like well what's
your job but you gotta have a career you
gotta you got to do this thing you can't
but they'll still reproduce probably
maybe over the course of many many times
that that because it's still a matter of
reproduction right yeah totally
totally so everything that happens after
you can reproduce is in this selection
shadow natural selection doesn't really
get molded by what happens to you later
so heart disease Alzheimer's those
things all happen so late right that it
didn't get weeded out by natural
selection right so I I don't know I
think that's that's a that'd be a great
movie what is it like in thirty thousand
years is everyone just like the kind of
mind that thrives in a corporate
environment because that's what's
expected I mean there's this really
narrow expectation and if you deviate
from that you're weird and dangerous and
you can still reproduce but then you've
got with suicide
you've got factors that could influence
that right and in sounds like a sci-fi
movie yeah it's it's a possible future
and so again if you want to learn more
about it I would recommend other
futurists besides the Unabomber but it
all starts there all good start there
but he you know got the manifesto
published in the New Year
times but well yeah that well that was
one of his demands so this this is
called I find that a little bit
paradoxical this philosophy is called
futurism of this thought that we should
that's just a a broad term for thinking
about a long long future yeah being
terrified of technology and its
influence that's being a Luddite that's
a like a different thing you could be
you totally love technology and think
that it is gonna bring the best future
possible so what do you think about Elon
Musk what do you think generally about
him what do you think about his plans to
call it colonize Mars do you think
that's do you think that that's a worthy
goal or is that a waste of time Oh
totally I think it's totally worth it
because we whether we like it or not are
sort of the autobiographies of the
universe he record information better
than the universe does it says Carl
Sagan is just great saying we are a way
for the universe to know itself right
yeah and it's not just its knowing in a
really rich way like we can write down
exactly what the temperature was every
day but it's hard to look back at you
know tree rings and glaciers and really
figure out what the temperature was on
January 12th 4 billion BC right but we
can record those things and I don't know
what the you know end purpose of all
that is but we can tell those stories
and nothing else can so so going to Mars
exploring it preserving how it is today
that's that's my big concern is making
sure that I don't know how you do it but
you section off we need to make sure
that as Mars is and has been for most of
our species existence is still there as
a historical artifact right so if you're
watching out there future people who are
colonizing Mars named a park after me on
Mars amen keep it natural guys we need
some natural parks and Marlies parts of
it right like we need to keep records of
the story because why is that important
to because most people say well it's a
it's a biological insurance it ensures
that human
we'll continue to thrive and exist I had
geing our bets like what's what is it
about the record-keeping that that's
more that's important to use because
what makes us different from everything
else in the universe there's nothing
bigger to it than that I'm not like
because then we'll all be happier it's
more like because at the end of the day
if our entire species died
Jupiter wouldn't even know yeah the moon
would keep orbiting yeah right the only
impact we have is records that also last
a long time so telling stories whether
they're fiction or not like they can be
made-up stories - that's a whole other
reflection of our minds that we get out
there that's there for after our Sun is
exploded we've still got a Google years
before the heat death of the universe
other living organisms can discover what
we have found and they will know the
universe better because of what we
recorded about it does this idea terrify
you of like an empty universe just no
conscious being like all this space all
these stars and planets and not a single
conscious being right this strange
thought it's a weird it's a weird
thought that at a certain point because
of entropy we will have no usable energy
anywhere energy will be completely
spread out there won't be more here and
less here and there won't be the ability
to put more energy in one place like to
make a battery right and so that's the
heat death there's just it's we're done
that like I said it's like at Google
years from now yes it's it's a long way
off but you know if organisms like us
live that long maybe we'll find a way to
feel like there'll always be some
there's always a way and I feel like
these theories are always changing - oh
like that's the only if only fifty years
ago everyone thought the universe would
crunch back it crunch people still do
think that's like ruled out it's not
like hey guys I've got the answer we're
gonna inflate forever it seems like
nature is always way more simple and
poetic and like the Big Crunch makes
like poetic sense and that it like
crunches up it comes out at big bangs it
crunches up I feel like the real answer
is probably something more
cyclical then it just like phases out
and disappears forever
that seems could be just seems unlikely
but I don't know why I don't I don't
think we well yeah we don't you know a
lot and you know if we need to escape
this universe and we will find a way to
enter another set of three it's gonna be
it's gonna be the our brains are gonna
be on a computer right I'll blow into
your mind that's the [ __ ] that's it
blackmail we were listening to I forget
if it was a podcast about these guys
working on AI mm-hmm and this whole
philosophical debate about keeping them
in a box you are you familiar with that
no because basically a lot of people are
afraid of AI right now and so they
didn't get into much detail but they
speak very metaphorically about keeping
it in some kind of box so that we can
get its help but we keep it caged up
because we're afraid of what will happen
if it's not caged right thank you is
with Sam Harris yeah Sam Harrison some
AI guys but there's this really big
debate going on right now with Elon Musk
and other people working on AI about
should we be afraid or is it completely
overblown and this is gonna be I mean
it's gonna be revolutionary one way or
the other but it's just something that
we should be afraid of it's very right
it's great this is real science fiction
happening it's ethical you know it's
like whoa wait a second if we can't be
sure that these you know a eyes aren't
conscious then yeah is it wrong to keep
them in a box but then you have to start
asking well what is it like even to be a
cockroach like that they're fantastic if
that was an AI we'd be like that's
genius this thing it finds food yeah
yeah could survive all kinds of things
so should we not even be killing
cockroaches if they have any kind of
semblance of goals for the future or
plans then it's a tragedy when they died
one of the more terrifying things I
heard from that podcast that I thought
was very thought-provoking is that we
create AI we can never know actually if
there's real true consciousness instead
of a AI right yeah I can't know if
you're conscious you could be a
philosophical signe I think I really
love that's true and that's why I love
to sing I think therefore I am
yeah because it's like you just know
that something exists by the very nature
of yourself thinking yeah acting stuff
so we create the super intelligent AI
that can reproduce it can get resources
it can build it can colonize you
creative against it can see reactive
things as though it's faylene thing
exactly it has families it colonizes
other planets but we never know if it's
conscious and and this guy he posed this
question that what if they're all
actually just ten boxes yeah and they
actually don't know or care that they're
alive and the universe ends up being
populated by essentially dead matter
right essentially just like a really big
virus yeah we are not to hate on viruses
they might have consciousness but not
only not yeah but what viruses are dead
by by some accounts right they're not
living is what they say is that yeah
it's when you get into like well what is
alive because a virus can replicate
itself in but I they're right on that
edge I think most people would say
they're not alive is what the virus is
so [ __ ] crazy right now it just
happens like like gravity happens like
it injects its
you know what it needs to reproduce
itself just by chemical reaction just by
mechanics and physics it's not deciding
or the you know the virus whole thing is
so it's such a trip it's like the
perfect antithesis of conscious life and
I think the analogy of that and like
these tin robots colonizing space is a
perfect example like this man-made
unstoppable virus that just an empty
universe and where we perish yeah for
whatever reason and these [ __ ] empty
robots just populate the universe but
are they empty you know the weird entity
and only way we can know is by asking
them and if they report back no I'm
aware that I'm aware
you have to take the word for it just
like I have to take your guys's word for
it when you tell me that you feel things
and that you're conscious and that
you're aware of your existence
it could be lying you could just be you
know I could be a brain in a bat we're
all just sent to ten boxes
yeah meet Bob and now this there's [ __ ]
with the viruses are being used now
engineered to treat like cancers right
yeah this is the new thing that they're
engineering viruses to go after certain
cancer cells and now it turns out that
viruses that I've been killing and
devastating living creatures for all
this time could end up being the the
answer to all these horrible diseases
yeah it's crazy yeah it's crazy and and
I mean they give us a great vessel for
look they already have the mechanism to
spread and and survive certain you know
traumas but if we get them on our side
but I wonder what the definition of a
virus is because when you really get
down into some of the most simple
viruses it's just like these two
proteins when they touch each other the
molecular bonds cause a folding that
releases the DNA or RNA or whatever it
is and it's just like what that's like
if you drip let go of a ball it falls to
the ground it just it just is a it just
happens due to natural laws not any kind
of biology or life yeah there's no
there's no like biology the one the rule
is like reproduction right but viruses
have that desire to reproduce don't they
oh I don't know if it's a desire or like
uh you know yeah it happens it just it
just happens the way something that goes
up comes down it just happens it's not
like the thing that's going up says yo
yo yo
we're gonna have a better existence and
we're gonna be able to reproduce if we
fall it just does fall and then some
things follow the laws of the universe
and make more of themselves and we're
we're related to them we came from them
all right let's tone it down here a
little bit let's um I've got some I have
I want to finish off with some really
important stuff I want to tone it down
let's come back to earth for a little
bit how does it feel being transcending
from a science channel to becoming a
living me as I was telling
you previously these sauce memes are in
very high demand the meme economy shows
that Vsauce memes are taking a very
strong upturn how do you feel about
having having ascended do you follow the
mean economy yeah big-time yeah yeah I
love that I love that kind of analytical
approach to because it means psychology
really it's like at what point is a joke
gonna be lame well it's my currency of
course i-it's like my you know you've
got a lot invested yeah economy yeah
yeah and I love that kind of idea of
like what I want to do an episode on the
psychology of lameness when something
becomes cringy and I roll II in old news
right because we're living in such a
fast-paced information world now that
we're we have many more examples of that
than we did decades ago but no I've
never seen any memes of myself what give
me a freakin break do you have any jokes
don't speak that's yeah no I'm a known
purveyor of saliva knowledge I didn't
choose that job but that's why I exact
it is it is something that I'm you know
a favor or dant get plug link me some
Vsauce memes let's do it me and reveal
right now the thing about memes of
course is that like at what point a I'd
loved it here this is me asking you a
question okay like do you respond to
memes other of create others have
created about you or are you ever afraid
that like if you acknowledge it it's it
loses its power
oh yeah well okay first of all yeah you
like I feel a I definitely see what you
mean because once you acknowledge it
then the the magic is lost right because
it needs to belong to everyone but you
right you don't want to be in on the
joke exactly are you right yeah no I see
what you mean yeah but I think I think
this is like we can review memes of you
it's fair it doesn't kill it mmm-hmm
meme review it doesn't kill it because
it's my I'm the one that's pushing it
yeah this is Aaron the driver see I'm in
the driver's seat
you're not like let's look at these
great memes of me that would kill these
great Vsauce memes could check this out
check yeah exactly because you can
embrace the meme sometimes you can over
brace me yes ready you embrace it so
hard you you strangle it in college
did you khaled embrace the meaning
strangled to me yeah and there's a right
and a wrong way to embrace it so that it
grows and can write your source of
creation where they maim you're afraid
of killing it you like me in other words
you love you like being a living me you
respect it clearly
I respect the the creativity that comes
from we're getting lots we're getting
1000 degree chainsaw verse 1 year old
infant I found gone wrong the hell is
this I don't I don't understand that's
just a video I made that's not it wait
your channel is called a rape breed and
the science man all right but come on
guys what was that there's also you know
there's obviously the like
inappropriateness of them which is is
where the comedy summarizing random boys
at the park yeah boy vase sauce all
right let's move on let's do you make
those no Ian may have just cooked those
up in the back all right
there there are some that are not so
offensive yeah but the kind of you know
edginess of them right like that's part
of the whole comedy series video man :
[Music]
you're a Titan bit are you familiar with
a shell Dolan guard no I'm not yeah yeah
that's powerful so so look at the this
creativity look at this Gil you inspired
that video
I can't edit that well yeah right and
and when I was first doing YouTube
videos I was taking politicians and I
was trying to do effects like that you
know get them involved in shows make it
look like they said
they hadn't said and that is a
phenomenal power that people haven't had
for a long time it used to be that if
you wanted to see a public figure or a
movie warp to mean something else you
had to see it on Letterman or something
like that no one else had those tools
but now with editing software and the
internet everyone clearly the Unabomber
hadn't foreseen meme economy otherwise
he would have come not written up he's
still alive I wonder if he's aware oh is
he the meme economy Walter yeah and the
power that people now have to take that
culture and make it their own right some
of the first videos I made were worth
that it was I made one called Ferris the
13th and I took Ferris Bueller's Day Off
and I used the voice over for a Friday
the 13th trailer so it made a comedy
look like a horror film and it's easy to
forget what it was like back in 2008
2007 to make something like that because
you had no gatekeepers allowed you to do
that you just did it and before you had
to be a Hollywood executive to make them
make something like that you had to have
money what is an editor's of the day and
age we live in now
by the way subscribe to Dylan dart
subscribe to Dollinger I feel like in
this day and age I don't know maybe it's
already a thing but I've been feeling
the desire for a form of therapy to
start taking classes of like working
with wood and building stuff that does a
form of therapy yeah that's kind of
brilliant I actually did some sculpture
classes and when I went to art school
and it's really fun when you can just
like drill a hole in a piece of wood and
that's actually like build a shelf full
of seven and it's a functioning object
it goes back to what we were saying of
doing something like meaningful with
your hands yeah yeah with physical
objects I find some of that in puzzles
you know in solving puzzles and in using
construction toys to make geometric
figures and stuff and you kind of
realize wow I haven't looked at a screen
I haven't been a part of the
technological world that's really that's
a really great idea I actually think
there's something to that yeah I mean
things you can do even without
technology like not wood stone tools but
just your own body like yoga or
calisthenics I guess like those kinds of
things that force you to be alone with
just the body are phenomenal yeah very
cool alright let's let's last thing we
had you on we didn't do this thing we do
this now with Oliver I guess it's very
interesting thing with our fans love it
so I'm gonna leave you with this one one
question here do you have any
interesting ghost stories paranormal
experiences alien encounters and it's
fine if you don't it's completely fine I
don't have any but it's just turned into
the segment it's just a little thing
ghost stories yeah I have none yeah okay
that's fair I know that's perfectly fine
people feel bad I don't have any but
sometimes you know you get surprised I
mean as you can imagine that's what I
expected like I'm not the kind of person
who's gonna go ghosts I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say Oh interesting I mean how
could something be right next to me
they're not here so to be in a fourth
spatial dimension right right and that's
what people have the turn of the century
the 1900s were really obsessed with they
were like where the heck is heaven right
because we're starting to feel like we
can't fly there maybe it's right next to
us in the way that on a sheet of paper
something can live on that surface and
only be 2d but something can be right
above it and look inside of it and know
what's inside of it what if that is
where these spirits and ghosts are and
after that in Cocoa if you're right that
was a great movie yeah but it's like I
mean I I would love to have an
experience but I sure that the same
sentiment is you sometimes people have
experience is so strong that you can be
a completely rational scientific person
and you're like yeah I believe in ghosts
so and and and that kind of experience
is very real yeah I mean if you think
you saw a ghost you thought you did
that's and and there are things we don't
know still if we we could discover a
hundred years that like oh no no when
you die you you enter a different
spatial dimension in your
there and you can be around all of us
but we can't see you because we don't
have eyes the point anywhere but in
these three right sure will we ever be
able to design an experiment that proves
that we find evidence of it I don't know
but
so in short no go stores no
I'm waiting I'm waiting for the day I
have a ghost story the closest I've had
is that a moth [ __ ] on my wall and I
thought it was blood but it was just
[ __ ] spooky and I was like I was like
ela there's [ __ ] blood running down
our wall and this was right after we
started the ghost stories thing and I
was like hold on I'm like that's more
Brown than red ah no no no there's a
giant monstrous [ __ ] on our wall is I
was scared for a moment moth blood is
not brown um what are the round in there
poop is red yeah was what moth goes
blood I love scary movies I love you
know like the conjuring the kind of like
spiritual Ouija board sort of stuff
because you love Lance Stewart sorry
those it's it's a it's a big part of our
like our minds create these stories and
that's very significant I think it's
what's more scary is what we can
convince ourselves of right then what's
real
may I suggest some video that we watched
recently I generally don't like spooky
films because I'm very I'm very easily
spit you're easily spooked but there was
a movie creep haven't heard of it oh my
god it's incredible yeah like it's not
it's not like corny what I don't like is
um graphic violence what about jump
scares I genuinely don't like jump
scares I don't like to see I like says I
guess what I like more is just suspense
right like that's the difference of a
good movie and like a corny like very
gory but this was a straddled the
perfect line between being spooky and
suspenseful career there's no violence
there's no there's something
it was so simply made right I really
enjoyed that it felt like I loved it
it's on Netflix okay cool is it all of
October I made my wife watch scary
movies every day I called it spook Tober
yeah hated it but we we wanted suspense
and we found ourselves actually
moving away from horror into the
suspense section because we wanted that
like get out right phenomenal right get
out Jerry because get out was more of
just a good film than it was like oh
this is a scary film yeah it wasn't like
you just jumped out of your seat and
also get this gore
it was more like yeah this the Stephen
King book the they made a movie out of
it but an author who is in a car
accident I want to say mercy hmm it's a
recent one or it's a classic it's not
recent but it's another one of those
like unsettling is read misery not mercy
misery so good oh we should watch that
ela yeah oh you totally should yeah
again it's just it's just off kilter
from reality hmm well what are you eight
to was great because it was kind of
funny
yep so it was I I found I found that
most good horror films there's an L
strong element of comedy and absurdity
and cheekiness to it yeah because you
have to you can't take yourself too
seriously when dealing with these kind
of issues
so yeah Stephen King by the way there
was a child orgy in that book I know if
you know that I know that because after
I saw the movie yeah I read the book
yeah and how do you feel about that cuz
I've only read about that scene oh you
know what I haven't read even read the
book so I'm curious what was your
reaction to okay well first of all the
book shows you why books and movies are
different and deserve to be treated
different look like a big boy when
someone says like yeah but did you read
the book yeah I know that's annoying but
books are so different because they
allow you to really get inside someone's
head for pages for hours for days but in
a movie you kind of gotta like get it
over with and like recollections people
have in a movie have to be done with
like recreated scenes and but with this
book you really get into the dark parts
of people's minds you can it cannot
translate to a screen anyway yeah when
when I started to get to that part of
the book they kind of hint at it before
it really happens and I immediately like
had to read like what critics have said
about why the heck that's in the book
because the Stephen King
health says well it represents this
transition from childhood to adulthood
this connection but of course the
hallway connecting the children's
library in the adult library also
represented that why did you also have
to have a graphic it's like a it's a
gangbang on this one girl as I as I read
about because right that's exactly what
it is
well it's just yeah I mean in its her
idea
mm-hmm but it's not really goes against
her character arc like is she's supposed
to all the characters become free in a
way right like like oh you mean my
medicine is just a placebo hmm
you know those were these big route
revelations and and you feel like the
the girl it gets there too but then
there's that scene and you're like what
I was reading about a lot of people were
just like he was on a drug-fueled
he was just doing like lines of cocaine
during that whole period and was just
yakked out and wrote it but still how do
you leave the ED that he's got a editor
I assume didn't seem central to the
story I also bought his book on writing
I haven't read it yet but I was really
like I got to know more about because
that scene aside the book is all of
Salem's Lot I read as a kid and I just
it's incredible yeah I mean I did a
whole episode on what is creepiness why
are things creepy and and you know his
idea of creepiness is a big part of the
episode so anyway but yeah
oh man that's weird and they're
troubling things in the book too
involving animals being harmed that it's
just a different kind of it's not horror
like Oh spooky clown it's horrible ice
why are we capable of that yeah well the
question is about that scene in
particular - was like was it necessary
to be in the book or it was just just a
sick weird thing he did - like [ __ ] with
the reader or maybe that's valid - I
don't know he did a lot us for sure to
mess with the reader III I mean he has
responded
this and I think he said that you know
if he did it again he wouldn't include
that scene no he did say that because I
thought he was defending well yeah as
far as I know his defense was I can't
believe that people are upset by this
and not like the actual violence and
whatever you know right but still it
just was a weird because what I love
about the book is that it
it's about belief if you believe that's
that the clown is real it is if you
believe that you can destroy it you can
and there's this great analogy he makes
to like look it took a lot of people to
create the myth of the vampire but
someone created the myth of the wooden
stake and in the book in it right the
kids think that the medicine is acidic
and it's gonna destroy the clown and it
does hurt them but once they become
adults and they don't believe these
things anymore they have to find new
solutions you have to believe you can
destroy it to destroy it and I had never
seen as a horror story that focused on
that aspect so yeah but that scene it
was it was weird too cuz it was like if
we do this we will learn how to get out
of the sewers
I was like I don't see the connection
right and they got out yeah it was
literally like after that scene they're
like oh cool you just take a ride over
there isn't it weird also the matter of
the time when you wrote the book I guess
those stuff like today it seems yeah
it's strange but maybe back then for no
you're right I don't know yeah and when
was it that actually probably the
eighties anyway let that's a great no.10
don't ya we got the Unabomber yeah you
know bombers manifesto we need a new
chapter for memes but in that book but
in 1986 according to you in 86 the year
I was born and if you if you want to
find your way out of a maze you have a
child
orgy oh no no it's not
okay well still on that
all right well oh yeah thanks guys for
watching damages singing let's end on
shredder cam I think that's a great idea
hmm
please go watch season 2 of minefield
support Michael in any way you can go to
brain candy and pick up some tickets
anything to supplement to that subscribe
to h3h3
be sure to next time you guys are it on
a Wednesday it's a different it's a
different time course follow follow
Ethan and Gila on the gone man Twitter I
love it by the fashions thank you I
appreciate that
thanks for having there's a lot of fun
yeah but if we got a weird we got a
little wild got a little one we went
there we got a little deep we came back
got a little scared and then we do a
couple spooks a couple hundred orgies
couple bomb the Unabomber he blew up the
apartment building right no he just
mailed pipe bombs oh that was the who
was the guy who blew up the apartment
building Jonathan Jonathan McVeigh who's
that Timothy McVeigh Timothy the
Oklahoma City yeah that's the guy
federal building so yeah yeah a
documentary on him and if you watch that
it's on Netflix it's fantastic you
should also watch the one on Ruby Ridge
because he was responding to Ruby Ridge
he was responding to the you know the
government and and its power over people
and it is so relevant today today I mean
it's it's the same world history main
important stuff let's get on Mars and
start recording data yeah in Michael
Stevens Park all right I'm calling him
now guys thank you so much for watching
as Michael was gracious enough to say we
are going to be live next week on
Wednesday with player unknown very
excited about that so please join us
then until then my friends I wish you I
do and with that I say adieu multi
shredder cam thanks for watching and
we'll see you guys next time
Tata